[Música]
y comenzamos la extracción en directo
hoy vamos hasta la capital chilena
santiago y es que mientras la mayoría de
los países del mundo olvidan la
mascarilla ante los bajos contagios de
kobe 19 el gobierno de gabriel boric
implementó una nueva estrategia
sanitaria conocida como seguimos
cuidando paso a paso esta consiste en
tres etapas y en la más grave de ellas
era obligatorio el uso del tapabocas
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal
patricia luna patricia bienvenida de
nuevo la nueva política llega cuando
chile se encamina a una nueva ola de la
pandemia cuéntanos en qué consiste este
plan y cuál es la situación sanitaria
así después fue simplemente el pasado 14
de abril cuando las autoridades
sanitarias chilenas permitían sacarse el
tapaboca los espacios abiertos pero
parece que esta medida no va a durar
mucho tiempo hoy entraba en vigor una
fase de medio impacto en 95 comunas del
país entre ellas todas de la región
metropolitana en total son 111 de las
345 comunas que existen en chile
aproximadamente un tercio de todos los
chilenos los que están en esta fase de
medio impacto que según el nuevo diseño
del gobierno de gabriel boric se divide
en tres etapas que están marcadas con
los colores del semáforo rojo amarillo y
verde nos encontramos ahora en esta
etapa amarilla que supone una
restricción en el número de aforo
especialmente y también la imposición de
la mascarilla en todos los espacios
cerrados esto ante el incremento que se
ha producido en la última semana
subieron los casos un 36% en las últimas
24 horas se registraban 4 mil 39 casos
la cifra más alta en el último mes en un
momento en el que la varia y una de sus
variantes la bea 2.0 mucho más
contagiosa que la inicial empieza a
marcar un punto a pie en todo el país y
se espera según vaticina los expertos
que a finales de mayo podamos estar en
medio de una nueva ola esto ante el
hecho de que en el país la tasa de
vacunación se encuentra bastante alta
son más de un 93 por ciento de la
población objetiva de 15-2 millones de
chilenos frente a los 19 que existen los
que ya han recibido la vacuna sin
embargo las autoridades también marcaron
que aquellas personas que no hayan
recibido una cuarta dosis de la vacuna
antes del 1 de junio verá suspendidas su
pase de movilidad esto ante el descenso
de las personas que han acudido a
vacunarse en los últimos días cuando en
el país también se baraja el uso de una
quinta dosis de la vacuna en este caso
para las personas más vulnerables en
este momento se vive una crisis de un
aumento de los casos que podría llevar a
una nueva ola en el país y a propósito
de la vacunación hay otra noticia y es
que la farmacéutica china sinovac inició
la construcción de su primera planta en
américa latina' para producir vacunas y
estará en santiago que detalles se
conocen
así es chile ya ha administrado más de
53 millones de dosis de vacunas y según
cifras del pasado martes muchas de estas
vacunas han sido dosis de la vacuna
china sinovac que permitió a chile
llevar a cabo su exitoso plan de
vacunación al lavado en todo el mundo
hoy mismo se iniciaba la construcción la
primera en américa latina y también en
santiago de la planta de china de
sinovac que fabricará 50 millones de
dosis anuales de vacunas entre ellas de
la cob y 19 pero también de la hepatitis
a y otras enfermedades esto en un plan
que supondrá una inversión de 100
millones de dólares y que se espera que
esté en funcionamiento en el primer
semestre de 2023 y que permitirá por
tanto a chile recuperar su capacidad de
producir vacunas algo que fue muy
importante en el país en las hace varias
décadas y que se había lamentado haber
perdido esta capacidad de producción en
los últimos meses especialmente con la
llegada de la cob y será por en tanto la
primera planta
si novak en américa latina' bueno
esperemos que chile así aumente su
capacidad de producción de vacunas
patricia gracias por estar con nosotros
y seguimos con más información